et sachez que groix n'est pas la seule
dans cette situation c'est le grand
désarroi sur la petite île doite situé
non loin de belle-ile là bas encore
aucun moyen n'a été acheminés eric
nejjar alain descormiers le long des
côtes de l'île doite sur les plages du
béniguet du salut s'ils ne peuvent qu
assisté impuissant aux dégâts provoqués
par la pollution le nettoyage n'a pas
encore commencé pour le moment comme
partout on se contente d'essayer de
sauver les oiseaux mazoutés échoué
c'est la seule chose qu'on a à faire
pour le moment
et puis attendre que ça passe
et puis les renforts qui arrive
peut-être
ce renfort on en a cruellement besoin
les plages les roches est touchée par la
pollution reste difficile d'accès et
l'on manque aussi de matériel watts est
une île qui ne dépasse pas les 350
habitants l'hiver one n'a pas de pot
c'est le magasin où on peut les acheter
comme ça des pelles et des bavures
certainement qu'il nous faudrait dépens
de l'eire déchirée par les planches et
autres enfin mode tout le matériel pour
manger les habitants de wad devront donc
patienter encore difficile de dire quand
arriveront les renforts la tempête aussi
empêche tous travaux de nettoyage sur
l'île on aurait préféré fêter noël
autrement aussi en été c'est plein de
serviette dans une serviette des
maillots de bain c'est jodie avoirs et
l'a arrêté catastrophe catastrophe
j'ai quitté mon habit de père noël pour
aller ramasser le goudron voilà le noël
de l'an 2000
et encore who what a échappé au pire
avant d'arriver sur l'île la nappe de
fioul échapper du pétrole erika a trouvé
sur son chemin belle-ile-en-mer
maigre consolation les îliens savent
qu'il faudra des mois au mieux pour
effacer toute trace de marée noire